Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
justice league snyder cut trailer breakdown
they just did a big ign fan fest and zack snyder
did a big panel talking all about the movies
some changes that he made what his plans for the
future were had he gotten to do his justice league
sequels so we'll break it all down and there's
also all the news about the new superman movie
that warner brothers is working on so i'll explain
what's going on with that at the end of the video
too getting a new superman movie probably not the
one you expected though be sure to subscribe if
you're new to the channel i'll be doing videos for
the snyder cut when it drops obviously it's four
hours long so there's going to be a lot of stuff
to talk about because most of the movie will be
brand new stuff that we've never seen before but
i'll just talk with the footage all the easter
eggs first and what zack snyder said about this
particular trailer then i'll explain all the other
things he revealed about the movie during his
big panel the way he talked about this trailer he
called it the motherbox origins trailer because it
sort of tells the origins of the box in the movie
the origins of the snyder verse and the origins
for all the different characters in the way that
they're portrayed on the different motherbox
panels you also probably noticed that the song
on the trailer is a little bit different i had to
change that just because of copyright because it
was a tom waits song and i don't have permission
to use his music in my videos the reason why he
said he used that tom wade song in the trailer
is mostly because it fit the style and mood
of the snyder cut but the trailer itself was made
as a result of a bunch of doodles and ideas that
he had for marketing the film that he worked with
warner brothers on but it starts with cyborg's
origin story the wheel and the football helmet you
see here just references the football game you see
in the trailers and then the car accident after
the fact that he gets into that winds up killing
his mother and causes his father to experiment
with the mother box turning him into cyborg we'll
see all that happen during the actual snyder cud
all that footage was deleted from the theatrical
cut there's like a whole big story for cyborg
that we never got to see and he's supposed to
be the linchpin of the movie he's sort of like the
heart of the snyder cut he's the one that brings
the team together so when they're referencing a
lot of their origin stories a lot of this stuff is
happening during the events of batman v superman
or just prior to the events of batman v superman
with a few exceptions for people like wonder
woman whose movie took place in the distant past
but then they go to batman's origin story in
another panel you see joe chill's gun his mother's
pearls their family's tomb wayne manor the bat
signal his very frank miller inspired bat suit
from batman v superman then you go to the flash's
origin story you see the speed force lightning
arcing across the panels of the mother box till
you get to flash's panel the clock behind him
just representing time travel abilities the speed
force flash point you see his mother's gravestone
nora allen here the microscope just referencing
his work as a forensic scientist at the central
city police department you see a couple other
worlds around the clock here just representing
multiverse travel that they'll get into during
the flash movie the way he talks about it even
though a lot of these characters he originated
in his movies which what he's calling the snyder
verse all the movies that he's made inside the dc
universe he considers his movies in the snyder cut
in particular his own little bubble of continuity
so he doesn't really reference anything that's
going to be in the flash movie or things that were
in wonder woman 1984 like it doesn't really get
into that because most of the movie was finished
before they ever started working on those other
dc movies he said that also includes the aquaman
movie because they didn't make that movie till
after he'd pretty much finished filming all of his
justice league movie even though they did have the
additional photography he talked about that too
so i'll explain he explained why he added joker
to the movie but then you go to another box in
aquaman's panel the tentacles of the kerathen
all around him his mother's trident the throne of
atlantis behind him too because he is the future
king of atlantis at this point he hasn't taken the
throne when justice league is happening yet then
you go to a different panel you get superman's
origin story the kent farm where he crashed the
kryptonian world engine from man of steel there's
a lot of man of steel references on this the
school bus from the flashback scenes the other
worlds around him and the red glow represent
krypton exploding in the path of his pod then you
travel through the mother box to the other side
and it all ends with wonder woman's origin the gas
mask from world war one all the german world war
one military drawings on the other side here steve
trevor's plane in the watch that he gave to her at
the end of the movie the monstrous looking head
seems like it's zack snyder's depiction of ares
even though they tuned him down quite a bit during
the movie the old timey camera just referencing
the picture of her with her friends that shows up
during the movies and then her sword and armor and
the chain around her then all three mother boxes
coming together combining into one like you see
during the justice league movie just to unleash
the anti-life equation or the unity or however
he's going to explain it in the snyder cut he
didn't really clarify that part i think just
because he didn't want to give away spoilers but
they talk about the unity during the theatrical
cut of justice league but obviously his movie is
very different and when he talked about darkseid
enslaving superman and all the nightmare scenes
he made a lot of references to darkseid using the
anti-life equation to do that so i don't know if
we're gonna see more easter eggs for the anti-life
equation in the snyder cut but just getting into
the stuff he revealed during the panel it was
pretty long he revealed some really cool things
he said that even though the movie we're gonna
see it's just a couple minutes beyond four hours
it's like four hours in a couple minutes with the
titles he said originally there was an even longer
version out there before they started cutting it
down to that four hour mark he clarified that
there were originally three justice league movies
that he wanted to make which i think i've talked
about in the past originally it was three movies
then the studio turned it into two movies and then
eventually just the one movie he said that justice
league 2 would basically be an entire movie set
during the nightmare sequence like a nightmare
movie all by itself in the future after dark side
has conquered the earth then the third movie is
when they eventually change everything and finally
defeat darkseid i did a video a couple years ago
after he revealed what the plan was for that three
movie justice league arc but he said the way he
sees it right now the studio isn't interested in
making his sequels never say never so he just said
i'll believe it when i see it he also said that
there are chapters in the movie and originally it
was his idea to break the release into like four
different episodes for the different chapters but
the main reason why they decided not to do that
not to release it in four different parts is
mostly for legal reasons like lawyers just got in
the way and it got really complicated so he said
okay it's just simpler to just drop it as one big
four hour movie but the title of chapter one is
don't count on it batman and it's about 40 minutes
long then chapter two is called the age of heroes
he didn't say how long that is but it's basically
four chapters total he talked about a cameo scene
during the movie that's gonna blow fans minds some
big deep cut even though he didn't reveal what
that was i believe he was talking about martian
manhunter because harry lennix also skyped in and
asked him a bunch of martian manhunter questions
for the fans i mean obviously he already knew it
it was mostly for the sake of the panel and the
fans like has martian manhunter been hiding out
this whole time so zack snyder explained that he's
been pretending to be this general character that
we first saw during man of steel than batman
v superman and now during justice league and
he was lying to superman and lois this whole time
sort of trying to push them in the right direction
for the benefit of humanity so it wasn't like
he was trying to gaslight the world or anything
like that he was trying to influence things in a
positive direction from behind the scenes he said
the movie ends on a massive cliffhanger so that's
probably going to be one of the first videos that
i do for the movie just explaining what's going
on with the ending and what his plans were for
the stuff that was going to happen after that but
a while ago there were rumors that he swapped some
of the green lantern stuff in the movie that he
had thought about doing for the martian manhunter
stuff like instead of some green lantern stuff
there's martian manhunter stuff but we'll see
because originally there was supposed to be
a green lantern post credit scene so i don't
know what happened to that in the snyder cut
hopefully it's still in there he said the reason
why he added jared leto joker to the nightmare
scenes in that alternate post-apocalyptic future
or mostly to deliver on the promise of batman
and joker's relationship in his snyder verse
like this self-contained bubble of continuity ben
affleck's batman and jared leto's joker had never
actually shared any scenes up to this point they
never had the opportunity the way he talks about
deathstroke in the movie too also makes it sound
like it's happening in this alternate nightmare
scene future he said he and batman deathstroke
and batman have struck a deal in a partnership
because there's a bigger enemy i believe
he was referencing darkseid in apocalypse
he also talked a little about the empty pod from
man of steel he said that it actually shows up
again during the justice league snyder cut but he
doesn't definitively answer the question of who
was in the pod although everybody believes that
it's a version of supergirl now there is a brand
new version of supergirl that they just cast for
the flash movie but the way he talked about the
empty pod he made it sound like whatever he was
planning for that is completely different from
what they're doing in the flash movie so whatever
plans he had for supergirl or this mystery figure
we won't see that happen in the flash movie he
also said that the black and white version of the
movie is called the justice is gray edition
and they're going to add that to hbo max
after they add the regular version at some point
then once everyone's actually able to go to movie
theaters again he'll release the movies both the
editions the black and white and the color version
in special imax theatrical releases so you will at
some point have a chance to see these in theaters
but just explaining what's going on with the new
superman movie announcement that they had this
past week so if you didn't see the news warner
brothers is developing officially developing a
new superman movie but here's the catch it's a
totally different writer with jj abrams no big
surprise there i'd always assume that he would
be the person to produce a new superman movie
at warner brothers but the rumor is is that
it's actually being developed as a valzod or
calvin harris superman movie so if you don't know
who those characters are they're two different
characters but they're basically multiverse
versions of superman it wouldn't be henry cavill
superman so the rumor is is that he might be out
but warner brothers hasn't said anything about
it they might also be doing it as a multiverse
movie and reference his superman in some way or he
might get a cameo scene because earlier last year
all the news outlets were reporting that he was
working on a deal to cameo in the other upcoming
movies like superman versus black adam or superman
and shazam 2. so it does sound like we will
see more of henry cavill's superman just not
in the way you expected but if you spotted any
other easter eggs in this trailer video that i
didn't mention in the video or in the big panel
that he did that i didn't talk about just write
them below in the comments and post your reactions
about the new superman movie news my Wandavision
finale video is gonna post next friday but i'll
be doing some bonus videos for it before then
falcon and winter soldier episodes are starting
real soon i'll be doing videos for all those as
well while you wait for everything click here for
my brand new Wandavision episode 9 finale trailer
and post credit scene video and click here for
that brand new spider-man 3 no way home teaser
trailer video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!